okay welcome back everybody from the
coffee session I hope you're all feeling
refreshed so we're very pleased to have
professor Fang Fang here as the next
speaker
he's the executive associate director of
The IDG McGovern Institute for brain
research at Peking University he's also
a professor of psychology and Dean of
the school of psychological and
cognitive sciences and director of
Beijing key Laboratory of behavioral and
mental health he obtained his PhD and
did postdoctoral work in brain and
cognitive sciences with Shanghai Daniel
Kirsten and Gordon leg his research
continued seeks to understand the neural
mechanisms of visual and cognitive
processing by combining neuroimaging
visual and cognitive stimulation
psychophysics and computational modeling
I found out that one of his heroes is mi
t--'s David Marr a hero of many and he
would like to understand visual
recognition well enough to duplicate
this in AI something that his work has
taken great strides towards across the
visual of arena of visual recognition
his title is IDG McGovern Institute at
Peking University past present and
future
[Applause]
so I sure disputing here is is the
highest viewing at picking University
which is the McGowan Institute for every
such as picking the University is
located in the English building but the
Institute will move to the new building
I will show later so we get together
here to commemorate mr. Patrick McGowan
so Patrick McGovern he was not only as a
successful business leader but also a
visionary support hardware research
together with his wife Laura he
established the IDG
McGowen still for burn research are
picking University the McGovern's have
interactive is picking University at
many levels from the university
leadership to students or kitchens
ranging from board meetings to
scientific symposium so our faculty
members and the students charges the
inspiration wisdom and generosity of
Patrick McGovern so first part is
talking about ours so the Institute at
Peking University was it established in
2012 that's seven years ago so with the
contribution from Pat and Laura so who
are committed to improving human welfare
communication and understanding so their
support for neuroscience so I show the
picture here
that's 2012 so our president our e^x e^x
e^x present Joe chiefin signed a
contract with Patrick and Laura just in
the women lake so at that time so II go
and show up in this picture so the MCO
can t have 26 neuroscientists and the
cognitive scientists from many areas
such as biology cognitive science
psychology chemistry physics and
computer science and psychology so we
aimed understanding the normal brain
functions and burn disorders so we use
various techniques from traditional
sacra Felix genetics to modern imaging
and the manipulation of molecule in your
own visualization and the functioning
human brains genomic and analysis of
diseases and the cognitive chase
so I show the board meetings so
immediately follow president Joseph M so
the university president was Professor
one girl that's in the first two picture
then the next present is professor Lin
Gemma
he's chemistries and professional Indian
has stepped down a lot to fall so
hopefully in the coming May so the
bottom eight meeting will invite our new
present hoping will show up in the
meetings
so I bring this picture here that's
happened in 2014
August 20 s so the Institute at picking
the university hold a memorial ceremony
in memory of Patrick at Peking
University so people on that day people
gathered in front of the site of new
building which was just gone broken and
to find the location of the Institute at
the ceremony at all on the streets
Chinese scholar Chi in front of the
uncommon building was named after
Patrick McGovern he's indicating that
Patrick spirit remain evergreen with us
so the members of Institute are
confident that we will make important
contributions and discoveries in our
research so I showed them then that's
five years later so we took the picture
a few days ago
that's a new building for the McGowan
Institute the total space is almost
10,000 square meters so the McGovern
Institute will occupy the third and
fourth floors of course including the
underground basement animal facilities
the space will be over 4,000 square
meters here's some internal pictures and
so she the student office and
experimental areas and also the the room
space for discussion and for
communications
so second part has show the faculty and
the activities so now we have a 20-6 and
this morning we have one more new PR
joint how ensure that we now have 27
faculty members so that's nine people
from schools and the cognitive sciences
that's myself
I'm study visual perception attention
awareness and song you study music Felix
hyung joong study perception action
decision-making on holo also show up
here so she'd study attention working
memory your oscillation researchers
studied New Economics and Schenley
studied visual cognition and we also
tailed to more people so we hung and
showing to study social neuroscience and
a Japanese scientist Eugenia
doing a declarative memory so we also
have seven people from the School of
Life Sciences and Duncan lova study
sensory neurobiology jamming certain
neural circuits are movements and the
somatic sensation
jinyoung new mechanism how
neurodegenerative disorders Symington
studied using the two photo imaging to
study the monkey vision Angele study
cell test mechanism in your degenerative
diseases the eagle for some reason he
didn't got visa
his research interesting is very broad
including all areas in neurobiology and
genetics are you lonely
he studied sensory neurobiology and
neuronal image we also have a faculty
member from physics hinges are mi to
study human brain and that's Health
Science Center how Pico that actually is
a medical school daijaan study the
neurobiology of mental illness mechanism
Union especially focus on the autism and
Charlie he also is here in this room he
study epigenetic bases in the biology of
brain aging and age-related related
diseases lingo studied the mental
illness and we also study the genetics
assistants susceptibility of mental
illness and young john studied as a
synaptic plasticity and learning and
memory and evolving here study the
nervous system signal transduction you
know we have a one faculty member from
the Institute of how molecule in
medicine
that's a children study neurobiology a
one professor from chemistry study the
chemistry enabled twos for neuroscience
and one more person studied
computational neuroscience and the brain
spied computation so we have area we
have many activities for example she'll
here it's a fifth AP are used in podium
on brain and the mind research in the
Asia Pacific areas so we invite people
from countries surrounding this Pacific
Ocean and that's happening 2014 and this
joint symposium with several McGowan
that's 2015 it's a symposium on synapse
and the brains
and the English summer 2016 summer we
have international
chronobiology summer school and every
year we recruit recruit topped our
undergraduate students from University
across China to attend the neuro and the
cognitive science summer school so every
year that 120 on the greatest and join
the summer school and interactive is our
effective members and that's the last
year we have neuroscience and artificial
intelligence we are doing meet that's
interdisciplinary workshop that's
happened in July 7 so the aim of this
workshop is to discuss the most recent
developments in neuroscience and is the
possible implication in developing brain
inspired machine learning algorithm and
AI so more than 20 experts throughout
the world give our lectures and in this
simple workshop the third part is about
our research so I briefly talk about
what happened in the labs in our
Institute so very recently that's the
last month so eros lab proposed a
concept now the thermochemical
connection has in title of all
neurotransmitters neuromodulators and
neuro peptides and the receptors and the
approach of chemically Atomics to chase
neuro circuits anatomically and
functionally and the ulos lime so the
research of eros love focus on the
synaptic transition between yours the
compressed inter interaction between
that neuron as well as a functional
modulation by distinct model modulators
call for new technology and could
potentially enable new funding so you
know in last year that's the development
of novel
encoded florescent sensor for imaging
neurotransmitters were selected as 2018
top 10 advances in life science China by
China and Chinese by Chinese union of
life science societies so I show the to
Stalin so in recent years so you know
slab focus on developing novel genetic
in encoded fluorescence sensors that
could sensitively morning to the
dynamics of specific neurotransmitters
so including as the calling dopamine
norepinephrine that this gpci activation
based the senses so called grab senses
are engineered by tapping into the
natural involved neurotransmitter
receptors GPCRs and converted the ligand
induce activation to the fluorescent
changes the sensor sensitivity has such
sensitivity faster response kinetics and
the superior specificity which can able
to track the new indigenious dynamics of
specific neurotransmitters in
distinctive behavior across multiple
animal models like fruit fly fish mice
and even non-human primates solutioning
tongue developed to fungal image on a
weak macaque we can image in thousands
of neurons in a weak neural so that
offer a possible way to look deep into
the newer basis of visual cognition so
this he also uses technique tools for v1
gyro actually can selectively for many
complex patterns also he reveals some
sparse coding mechanism for Iran euros
so Ian Johnson lab he studied the house
hammers diseases so he/she investigate
the role of Jackson in accents guidance
and neuronal network formations
so the found addressing promotes the
plastering of neurons and axon guidance
interacting with collateral cancer so
the Stata provide excellent example of
hi guidance reception's receptors
interaction and therefore has great
impact on axon guidance so Duncan's life
he is working many folks on the mapping
the connectome from a photo in German in
Joseph's law that's a new covering his
new car discoveries hub organize the
parallel circuits that students study
and in the school of the cognitive
sciences so professors shouting Joe now
he's so he has three utilized so why the
social neuroscience and the social
economics which are related to the
social cognition social emotion and the
social decision-making and he is also
interest in the language processing
including visual and spoken language
comprehension and the development of
reading ability in normal and
destruction children so reasonable focus
on the neural pragmatics so the follow
slam he's used eg and amici just
investigate the temporal dynamics in
attention and working memory in humans
they are particularly interesting
knowing how multiple object as well as
the other relationship are maintained
and represent in the attention the
working memory
so in arista world publishing he life
her group funded sequentially memorized
item a series and reactivate during
memory retention and surprisingly he are
temporarily compressed and a backward
manner so this fast and that
reply profile is a further founded to be
closing our associate with the recency
effect in secrets memory behavior so
this also some other amici start study
and visual attention study and is the
feature integration study and the
lucious lab his his studies how the how
the stimulus during sleep can affect a
social decision
it's very interesting that publishing
the Elife and Lucia also has a paper in
the nature communication issue the
function of the basal ganglia in the
social decision-making so the damage to
the pencil vessel gangling will affect
the decision will induce decision-making
deficits deficit especially in the
social behavior so finally in my lab so
we I study I use a brain imaging on TMS
to study the saliency map and the
priority map in the visual cortex so we
identify the science in mapping we won
and the priority map in the actual
Street View area that's a way to end the
history I also study the perceptual
learning so I show the perceptual
learning can modify the functional
specialization of visual cortical area
rather just simply enhance the function
so if in my lab it's the first time to
find perceptual learning of conscious
detection in human Elgin we identify the
M layers energy a responsible for
account for contrast learning so two
more slides for the future so in the
coming May so the China brain project
will start so I shoot a framework of
China brain project so we call the one
body two wings so the body is
understanding your basics of cognitive
functions and the develop of Prayer
researcher technology
proper platform the two wings is on one
side is a development effective
approaches in early diagnosis and
intervention of parentis orders so the
other wing is developer brains machine
intelligence technologies that's the one
body to wing plan so English sub brand
project and the project the Megami
Institute at picking the university will
play a major and even essential role in
this project a key component in this
parent project is a Chinese Institute
for brain research was established last
year so aro is a co-director of this
Institute so I show some picture for the
photo ceremony for the history for the
establishment serpentine ceremony so
okay that's my brief introduction of the
our Institute at peak near University so
thank you for your attention
[Applause]
okay we have time for some questions any
questions the audience
do you have any does the Institute have
any formal relationship with sort of the
computer AI machine learning part of
Peking University how close is that
relationship yeah that's the next week
so will the picking over University will
establish a school or Institute of AI
okay that this will be announced in
that's next week
so I'm afeeling to that school and the
prophets assume he's also a PI of how
Institute he is also official member of
that school any other questions
after that breaking news I was wondering
if you just you know yet how McGovern
Institute at PKU will specifically
benefit from this the new China brain
initiative I mean how's that gonna work
well well the brain initiative be
funding research within PKU had how will
that work there will be many broad
application material so we apply the
grant there were also some special
program to support young scientists
which means ages below 45 years old and
the reason it last year the university
also give us 15 new Pi positions so we
can recruit 15 you PI's and also 2000
PI's that's a lot of new positions and I
had a question about the chemo
connectomics which is a very grand
vision is yeah is this something that
multiple labs are participating in it
Peking University
see the house walk okay thank you
[Applause]